my name is tess winlock i'm a software
engineer at google here's a question how
does a picture text message or email get
sent from one device to another
it isn't magic it's the internet a
tangible physical system that was made
to move information
the internet is a lot like the postal
service but the physical stuff that gets
sent is a little bit different instead
of like boxes and envelopes the internet
ships binary information
information is made of bits a bit can be
described as any pair of opposites on or
off
yes or no
we typically use a one meaning on or a
zero meaning off
because a bit has two possible states we
call it binary code
eight bits strung together makes one
byte one thousand bytes all together is
a kilobyte 1000 kilobytes is a megabyte
a song is typically encoded using about
three to four megabytes it doesn't
matter if it's a picture a video or a
song everything on the internet is
represented and sent around as bits
these are the atoms of information but
it's not like we're physically sending
ones and zeros from one place to another
one person to another
so what is the physical stuff that
actually gets sent over the wires in the
airwaves well let's look at a small
example here of how humans can
physically communicate to send a single
bit of information from one place to
another so say we could turn on a light
for a one or off for zero or use beeps
or similar sort of things of like morse
code
these methods work but they're really
slow error prone totally dependent upon
humans what we really need is a machine
throughout history we've built many
systems that can actually send this
binary information through different
types of physical mediums
today we physically send bits by
electricity light and radio waves
to send a bit via electricity imagine
that you have two light bulbs connected
by a copper wire if one device operator
turns on the electricity then the light
bulb lights up no electricity no light
if the operators on both ends agree that
light on means one and light off means
zero then we have a system for sending
bits of information from one person to
another using electricity
we have kind of a small problem if you
need to send a zero like five times in a
row well how can you do that in such a
way that either person can actually
count the number of zeros well the
solution is to introduce a clock or a
timer
the operators can agree that the sender
will send one bit per second and the
receiver will sit down and record every
single second and see what's on the line
to send five zeros in a row you just
turn off the light wait five seconds the
person on the other end of the line will
write down all five seconds five ones in
a row switch it on
five seconds write down every second
obviously we'd like to send things a
little bit faster than one bit per
second so we need to increase our
bandwidth the maximum transmission
capacity of a device
bandwidth is measured by bit rate which
is the number of bits that we can
actually send over a given period of
time usually measured in seconds
a different measure of speed is the
latency or the amount of time it takes
for one bit to travel from one place to
another from the source to the
requesting device
in our human analogy one bit per second
was pretty fast but kind of hard for a
human to keep up with so let's say that
you want to actually download a three
megabyte song in like three seconds at 8
million bits per megabyte that means a
bit rate of about 8 million bits per
second obviously humans can't send or
receive 8 million bits per second but a
machine could do that just fine but now
there's also a question of what sort of
cable to send these messages over and
how far the signals can go with an
ethernet wire the kind that you find in
your home or office or school you see
measurable signal loss or interference
over just a few hundred feet
for the internet to work all around the
world we need to have an alternative
method to send bits really long
distances we're talking like across
oceans so what else can we use well what
do we know that moves a lot faster than
just like electricity through a wire
light
we can actually send bits as light beams
from one place to another using a fiber
optic cable a fiber optic cable is a
thread of glass engineered to reflect
light
when you send a beam of light down the
cable light bounces up and down the
length of the cable until it is received
on the other end depending on the bounce
angle we can actually send multiple bits
simultaneously all of them traveling at
the speed of light so fiber is really
really fast
but more importantly the signal doesn't
really degrade over long distances this
is how you can go hundreds of miles
without signal loss this is why we use
fiber optic cables across the ocean
floors to connect one continent to
another
in 2008 there was a cable that was
actually cut near alexandria egypt which
really interrupted the internet for most
of the middle east and india so we take
this internet thing for granted but it's
really a pretty fragile physical system
and fiber is awesome but it's also
really expensive and hard to work with
for most purposes you're gonna find
copper cable
but how do we move things without wires
how do we send things wirelessly
wireless bit sending machines typically
use a radio signal to send bits from one
place to another
the machines have to actually translate
the ones and zeros into radio waves of
different frequencies the receiving
machines reverse the process and convert
it back into binary on your computer so
wireless has made our internet mobile
but a radio signal doesn't travel all
that far before it completely gets
garbled this is why you can't really
pick up a los angeles radio station in
chicago
as great as wireless is today it still
relies on the wired internet if you're
in a coffee shop using wi-fi then the
bits get sent through this wireless
router and then are transferred to the
physical wire to travel the really long
distances of the internet
the physical method for sending bits may
change in the future whether it's lasers
sent between satellites or radio waves
from balloons or drones but the
underlying binary representation of
information and the protocols for
sending that information and receiving
that information have pretty much stayed
the same
everything on the internet whether it's
words emails images cat videos puppy
videos all come down to these ones and
zeros being delivered by electronic
pulses light beams radio waves and lots
and lots of love
you